[SQUEEKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: All right.
Sorry about this.
Hello.
There's some internet problems.
I was just actually talking
to MIT's president, who
was in the economics
department, talking how MIT can
be a leader in technologies.
Apparently, good internet
is not a part of that.
But anyway, so
we're going to play
a number of games which
are standard games
to measure social preferences.
You might have a lot of
questions about those
eventually, you
know, what exactly
do they measure,
how do we interpret
certain results, and so on.
We're going to discuss these
in the next few classes,
but for now,
essentially, I just want
to show you how
these games work.
You can sort of
experience them pretty
close to what an actual
participant of such a game
would experience.
One big difference, of course,
is that usually, these games
are played in private.
Usually, you shouldn't talk
very much to your neighbor.
One big difference
as well is like,
we can actually
implement some of these,
randomly implement some of the
choices that are being made,
so that makes it
sort of more public
than in a typical experiment.
So you know, you should be aware
of that like whatever choices
you may make, whether
they're nice or not,
they might actually be
implemented and be public,
so that may or may not
affect the way you choose.
You should sort of choose
truthfully or the way
you would like to choose.
Don't let that sort of
influence you too much.
OK.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to start with the
simplest of our games,
which is called the dictator
game, which you can see here.
Can you guys see the game?
Can you join?
So try to join
the game as it is.
So the way this game works is--
I hope these inspections work.
OK, so the way this
works is essentially,
it's a split the pie game.
We're going to figure out
what's going on with the volume
because it's a different
laptop, but essentially, the way
this works is like you're
going to be endowed
with an amount of money.
There's going to be two people.
There's going to be
essentially what we call
the divider or the dictator.
That's the person
who gets the money.
That person can
decide how much money
he or she wants to share
with another person who
was randomly selected.
The amounts will be-- this is
so far entirely hypothetical--
so the amounts will be
here, currently, it's $100.
I hate to break it to you.
You will not be able
to win $100 today.
I know, I know.
It's $100.
You can essentially decide
between you and a randomly
selected other
person how much you
would like to give of that
money to that other person.
It's the simplest of our games.
There's going to be the
divider and the receiver.
The receiver actually
does nothing other
than just receiving
money potentially.
The divider is the
person to do that.
OK.
Again, I'm going to show
you some results in a bit,
but one big issue that people
often have about these dictator
kinds of games is to say,
well, do you need real stakes
or do you need like
fake stakes and so on.
So what I have here
is I have some candy
and I have some apples,
and later some money.
I'm going to start with candy.
So these are Swiss chocolate.
So the way this
is going to be is
like there's going to
be always 10 of them,
so 10 is sort of like
the overall amount that's
being shared.
Now, what I'm going
to do is you're
going to decide as if you
were going to be selected.
Of course, I'm going to only
select one pair of people,
and that pair is actually going
to be actually implemented, OK.
And that is going to be 10, and
sort of like the 100, you know,
the percentage of the
candy that's being shared
is going to get to
the other person.
You should probably
use round numbers.
Otherwise, you have to sort
of like share them in parts.
I'm going to pick a number, 50.
So this will be
hopefully working.
It's Brian and Jackie.
So Brian was the dictator,
yes, the person giving?
Yes?
Where's Brian?
What did Brian do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There we go.
So here's your candy.
You can pick it up.
So this is sort of the issue
with the public version
of this.
You should feel
free to do whatever
you would like, of course.
Now, we're going to
do the same thing.
I brought 10 apples as well.
We have BG, whoever you are.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, and how
many apples did you--
AUDIENCE: I took three apples.
PROFESSOR: That's
three apples for you
and seven apples
for Lauren, I guess.
Here you are.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: They're good apples.
You can share them with
others as well if you like.
Now we're going to do the
typical version of this,
which is money.
Usually, people do this
with $5, $10 and so on.
We're going to do
$5 now, so we have
to figure out some way of
sharing it, Venmo or whatever.
I'm not quite sure, but I'm
sure you'll figure it out.
Number five.
MJ?
What'd you do?
AUDIENCE: I gave $2 or 40%.
PROFESSOR: I see.
You have to figure out some
way of giving $2 to Isabel,
wherever she is.
But here's the $5.
So now, something
that people often say
is like, well, maybe for
$5, is that a lot of money?
Maybe not, so
we're going to do--
maybe the stakes matter, and
some sort of small stakes
and so on, people
decide in certain ways.
Now I don't have a lot
of money, actually.
This is mostly like, I don't
have more cash with me,
so like the largest
stake I can do is $20.
So we're going to, with $20
now, do the exact same thing.
All right, how about number 80?
Alvin and Julia,
what did you do?
AUDIENCE: I gave $5.
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
Here you go.
You have to figure out a
way to actually do that.
Now there's a couple more
things that, perhaps, one
wants to vary here.
So one is communication.
So far I think you're not
allowed to communicate.
Is that right?
So you could not communicate
with the other person.
So now what we're going
to do is like a version--
the exact same thing.
I think that this will
be $10 but the same,
but now it actually
allows for communication.
So now the sender and the
receiver can communicate.
The receiver can, sort of,
try different things to,
like, influence, perhaps,
the descender in some ways
of eliciting more money.
So Jenka and [INAUDIBLE],,
where are you?
AUDIENCE: We
haven't [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: What was that?
You haven't decided, no?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What was that?
AUDIENCE: Seven.
PROFESSOR: I see,
and what was the--
did you get any
message that conveyed
or that made you nicer or no?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I was going
to keep everything to my self.
But yeah, I was
going to [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: I see.
So some communication that
seems to help this case.
So here's $10.
You have to figure out how
to actually now give $2.
Now another I that
you might think
might matter quite
a bit, which is
I'm, sort of, like putting
you on the spot quite a bit.
Like, I'm sort of like
publicizing how much money you
gave in front of everybody.
So in some sense, you might
want to actually keep the $10
or you might want to give a
lot or whatever and, like,
by just the fact that like
showing that to everybody
might influence your choices.
So we're going to do one
version, which is not
quite private but, sort of,
close to getting private,
which is like I'm just going
to announce which team it was.
And at the end of
the class, you'll
tell me what the
outcome was and you
get the-- or I guess, so you
see what the other person does
with you.
I see.
So then the two of you
can just essentially then
sort of split the money.
It's, sort of,
not quite private,
because the other
person obviously you
have to interact
with another person.
You should keep that
in mind, but it's
not like everybody in
class will notice it, OK.
Is it clear what
I'm asking everyone?
Yeah, so this is private
to the extent like private
towards your other classmates
except for the person
that you're matched with, OK.
So this is, again,
$10, and this is
the last $10 I actually have.
So I have more candy.
All right.
All right, so here--
where is [INAUDIBLE]?
Here.
So you get the $10.
You just have to
find your partner.
Who is it?
OK, so you have to, sort
of, settle that with her.
I'll stay out of this.
OK.
We're going to do more.
And this is the last one.
We're going to do
more of communication.
Perhaps you learned about how
to best communicate or the like.
I think, in most of
the remaining grounds,
we're just going to do a 10
candies or 10 chocolates,
whatever each.
So this one is, again,
with communication.
So you can chat and try
to figure out perhaps,
as a receiver, how to
best influence the sender.
All right, so let's see.
By the way, you can
be repeatedly chosen.
So we have E1.
What did you do?
AUDIENCE: 50/50
PROFESSOR: Nice to hear.
And here's Arthur.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Here's
your other part.
These are yours, yeah.
Go for it.
OK, so what are
some good messages?
Or what are some
compelling messages
that you received of any--
or maybe funny ones?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What was that?
AUDIENCE: Lactose intolerant.
PROFESSOR: You are lactose
intolerant or the receiver?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
The giver was
actually [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: I see.
AUDIENCE: They're
giving everything.
PROFESSOR: I see.
So here's a giver that
is lactose intolerant.
You could have given it,
instead of the other classmate,
you could have also just given
it to your friend as a giver.
But yes.
What else?
Was there any
compelling messages
that you received that actually
worked or did something?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I wasn't deciding,
but the person told me,
that if I tell them a joke
that makes them laugh,
they'll give me chocolate.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And did you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
They gave me 40, so--
PROFESSOR: Not bad, so--
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe you need to work
on the jokes, but yes.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, so now
we're going to choose--
play a second game, which
is called the-- sorry,
let me close this-- which is
called the Ultimatum game.
So the Dictator game is
a nice game in a sense.
It's a very simple game.
It's a very stark game
and very, in some sense,
good at capturing a
form of pure altruism.
Here's your money.
Here's the other person.
How much money you want
to give for that person?
There's often, no communication.
Often, it's even
anonymous, and so on.
So it's essentially,
just like, how much
do you care about yourself,
versus some other person?
So that's very simple.
But when you think about
real-world situation,
often, there's
interactions across people.
And the Dictator game cannot
really capture that that well.
So one of the second
perhaps most famous
or a game [INAUDIBLE] is what's
called the Ultimatum game.
We have, again, instructions.
I think you can't really
necessarily hear the narration,
but--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- You're going to be
randomly placed into groups.
PROFESSOR: Sort of.
- One player in each
pair is the proposer.
The other is the responder.
The first thing that will
happen is the proposer
proposes how to divide a sum.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Does it work?
No.
sorry.
So there's a proposer,
and there's there's a--
[INAUDIBLE], turn this off.
There's a proposer,
and there's a receiver.
The proposer, as in
the Dictator game,
proposes a sum amount
of money, as you see.
And then the other person,
who is the receiver,
the responder can
accept or reject.
OK?
So if somebody says, if I have
10 candy, if I offer you 1,
you might say,
that's not very nice.
And you might reject it.
Or you might say,
actually, I'd rather
have one candy than zero
candy, and I accept it.
And for each of these amounts,
you can make a choice.
But when you are the
first person choosing,
you need to take
into account what
the other person might do for
different offers that you have.
If the offer is rejected, you
essentially-- neither of you
receives anything.
If it's accepted,
it's just implemented
as what the proposal was.
Any questions on that?
OK.
And we're still playing
for Lindt chocolates.
[CLASSROOM CHATTER]
AUDIENCE: I did
50/50 [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Wise
choice, Here you are.
So Vijay, and
yeah, Here you are.
OK.
So we're going to do the--
let me see here.
[INAUDIBLE]
I see.
We're going to play
the same thing again,
but in rotated roles.
So that's usually not what
people would necessarily do.
Because usually, it would be
essentially one-shot games.
It was very clean in the sense
of expectations are clear.
This is a little bit just for
you to see the other side.
I think this is now--
I think it is with
the same person.
It might just be that
the roles are rotated.
I don't know if you can see what
the other-- can you actually
see the name of the other
person when you player, or no?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I see.
So I think it might
not be the same person.
Sorry, I should know this, but.
[CLASSROOM CHATTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Guess that's you.
PROFESSOR: Here you go.
I think she's up there.
Now we're going to
do the same thing,
but entails communication.
So that is to say
now, as a receiver,
you can talk to
the other person.
You can discuss.
Or as a giver, you
can discuss about,
if I make you this offer,
will you accept it or not?
And of course, the receiver
will have some thoughts
and try to sort make
the case of yes or no.
And you'll see that
has a somewhat slightly
different dynamic.
So again, same game now, except
for now, there's communication.
You can talk to
the other person.
One person is
playing with a robot,
so I guess you can't really--
[LAUGHTER]
--communicate.
Sorry.
Because it's just because
there's uneven numbers,
and I'm trying to finish up.
All right, so--
AUDIENCE: Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
The person gave me 100.
PROFESSOR: Did you accept?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I accepted.
PROFESSOR: There you go.
[LAUGHTER]
Lucky you.
AUDIENCE: But who is it?
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Very nice of you.
AUDIENCE: Oh, well,
I'll pay you back.
PROFESSOR: Are you the lacto?
Are you the lactose intolerant?
No.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, now we're going
to do the same thing again
in private, just to see
whether your choices in private
perhaps are different from the--
so it is in private
with communication,
so as in you can communicate.
But again, it's not
public, at least
to your other classmates,
what is actually
the outcome of the game.
I think I'm running out
of Swiss chocolates.
So now you have to get
some Snickers instead--
AUDIENCE: Woo, woo.
PROFESSOR: --which is
worse, I think, but anyway.
What did you offer?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: I probably
received three--
AUDIENCE: Oh.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Three--
did you say 330?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I gave
him 3.1 chocolates.
PROFESSOR: You have to--
[LAUGHTER]
You guys can deal with that.
Here you go.
I stay out of this.
AUDIENCE: He's [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you very much.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: All right, we
can do one more of these.
I also have--
I brought some
chocolate bunnies.
These are very nice
bunnies, so here you go.
This is again with
communication.
So I was saying this is private.
I guess it wasn't private.
Sorry.
Forget about this.
This is in public
with communication.
So I should have been clear.
Isabel and Hannah.
What did you do?
AUDIENCE: We did [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And it was accepted?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: All right, lucky you.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so now, one main
thing about these games
is, when you notice this,
it's like, in particular,
from the receiver's
part, there's
only one action that you see
for one realization, right?
So it's not very efficient
in terms of eliciting
a lot of information.
In the sense of if I ask you,
how much money did you give?
And I'm going to see what
you do as the first mover.
And then, for a
specific realization,
you see, what does this
person do as a second mover?
Instead, what you can
do is we can use what's
called the strategy method,
which we are, in some sense,
already doing, in the sense
of the strategy method
is to say, in case
a certain thing,
in case a certain
situation occurs,
and that situation
will be implemented,
what would you do
in that situation?
And there's a
positive probability
that this actually happens.
And so therefore,
people are incentivized
to behave optimally.
In the sense, that's exactly
what we're doing right now.
In some sense there's
80 different pairs
that are playing, and I'm
randomly just quasi randomly
selecting just one.
So this is already
a strategy method.
In a sense, I'm
asking you, in case
you are selected, what
would you like to do?
So I'm eliciting
information from 80 people
at the same time,
while only having
to pay out 10 chocolates or
chocolate bunnies, or whatever,
at one time for the result.
So that's essentially
a way of creating.
If you wanted to run
large experiments,
that's a way of
running experiments
where there are stakes.
And sometimes, it doesn't
matter what you choose,
but it's much cheaper to do and
much more feasible to do so.
Now, the strategy method is
going a little bit further.
What the strategy method
essentially is doing,
it is essentially just
asking you explicitly,
it's asking you
explicitly as a proposer,
how much would you offer?
So it's asking
essentially both people.
As a proposer, each person is
asked, if you were proposing,
what would you do?
And then it's
asking each person,
as a responder,
what's the smallest
offer that you would accept?
Notice, if I have those two
pieces, if I match two people,
I can play the entire game
for any realization, because I
know, essentially, the
fully contingent plan.
In that way, I'm eliciting
way more information
than just realizing-- and
essentially, for each person,
I'm going to elicit both what
they're doing in both roles.
And for the responder,
I'm eliciting also,
for all potential
realization, as opposed
to just if you
received $3 or $5,
or whatever, what would you do?
OK, so we're going to
do that right now I
guess with Snickers.
So now it's not clear
who actually your partner
is, because now it's
essentially you're choosing
for all contingent plans.
So it's not obvious what your
other partner will actually do.
You are essentially
deciding, independent of what
my partner does, for all
scenarios what I'm going to do.
And then, essentially
randomly, you
will be matched with somebody.
So why don't you tell me two
numbers between 1 and 60.
AUDIENCE: 23.
PROFESSOR: 23 and?
AUDIENCE: 52.
PROFESSOR: 23 and 52.
So I'm going to just
pick number 23 and 52.
We're going to take the
offer from, what, 23
and then the response from 52.
And I asked you to remember
what you chose, hopefully.
So 23 is--
I don't know how to
pronounce your name--
[INAUDIBLE]?
How do you pronounce your name?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE],,
what did you propose?
AUDIENCE: I proposed to do half.
PROFESSOR: Half?
OK.
And then what did
you do, the 50--
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: 52, which is Brandon.
So now the question
is, for half,
if you were offered
half, Brandon,
what would you actually do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And you'd
also accepted it
earlier in your round?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Yes, here you go.
And so essentially,
that's the way
this is usually implemented.
So now essentially, for
that specific contingency,
that's now being implemented.
But now I know
essentially what Brandon
would have done
for all scenarios,
because he gave me his
fully contingent plan.
We're going to do the exact
same thing again, in case
this wasn't fully clear.
So I don't know
actually why they
are making groups out of this.
But whatever, it's fine.
Abby?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
What did you propose?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Eight?
AUDIENCE: 50.
PROFESSOR: Was that 30?
PROFESSOR: 50-- sorry.
And--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: But you--
PROFESSOR: No.
Sorry.
It was 8 and?
AUDIENCE: 13.
PROFESSOR: 13 is Brian.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So we've got--
here you go.
You guys are pretty nice.
[LAUGHTER]
In previous years,
we're not that nice.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right.
So now we're going to
play the third game, which
has been used a lot in
this literature, which
is called the Trust game.
The Trust game works as follows.
So there is a person
who is the investor, who
gives some amount of money.
And so let me just--
OK, where's the video?
There's supposed to be a video.
Oh, here.
Sorry.
All right.
So they call it an investment
game, a trust game.
There's the investor, and
there's the responder.
The investor-- why
is this so slow?
OK.
So the investor
and the responder
have some amount of money, which
is a little bit contrived here.
But anyway, let's
assume that's true.
The investor chooses
how much to send.
This is the investment.
The responder gets the
investment plus a multiplier.
The multiplier here is
usually two or three.
And then the responder gets
essentially the investment
plus the multiplier
and then can decide
to respond and send money back.
OK?
So in our case, I guess
this is a little tricky
to do with candy.
But suppose the investor
has 10 to start with.
You can now decide out of
the 10 how much you're going
to give to the other person.
That is multiplied by 3.
I need to make sure
we have enough candy.
I think I do.
That is multiplied by 3.
And then the other person
can decide to send some back.
OK?
And so you get the issue that
essentially, on the one hand,
you want to send a lot, to get
the other person to have a lot
to be able to send you back.
But of course, it could
also be that you send a lot,
and the other person
says, thank you very much,
and doesn't send you anything.
OK?
OK, so this is
without communication.
And we'll do one with
communication after that.
And why don't you take these two
and divide in those fractions
that you have.
How about this?
So usually, this would be
obviously with real numbers,
done properly.
AUDIENCE: Oh, three?
PROFESSOR: No, no,
just divide it.
I think roughly half is fine.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you, [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
this is a little
tricky with these numbers.
AUDIENCE: OK.
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
Then we will use
this for the next.
I'll get these.
AUDIENCE: You can
do the next one.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, so we can do the
same thing with communication.
So now you can essentially,
before the first person makes
their first choice or where
before, when the person is
making the response choice,
you can communicate and talk
about what you might do in the
future, which may or may not
be the truth, of course.
We have Jodi and Sarah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Hi.
What did you give and receive?
AUDIENCE: She gave me all of
it, and I gave half of it.
PROFESSOR: So that's, in some
sense, the ideal scenario,
because the other person
had a lot of faith
in their classmate,
perhaps because it's
in public, because
perhaps because they
think their classmates
are really nice.
And so you gave a
lot to start with.
And then so that was
multiplied, and then
you actually got a lot
back, which doesn't always
happen either.
So I think you could
just, whatever this number
is, and divide it according
to the actual division of what
it is.
So now we're done
with those games.
What I'd like you to
do is-- so next time,
we're going to discuss in
detail each of these games.
And if you want more
rigorous research
in a sense of rigorous
versions of this research,
and trying to understand,
when you do this a bit
more carefully, in terms
of, experimental economists
are extremely careful
in their procedures
and in their ways in which
they present information,
and so on and so forth.
So what we just were
doing was pretty sloppy
by those standards.
So what can we learn
from this research
that does it very carefully?
And what does it predict, when
you think about, OK, these lab
games, in some sense,
they are fairly contrived,
what can we learn actually?
Are they predictive of
real world behaviors?
If you have any
observations about things
that you have learned or
thought that were interesting,
and so on, feel free to
share them on the forum,
anonymously, if you like.
And I can discuss
some of the things.
This could be either anecdotes
about messages you received
or things that happened.
I can then look at these and
share them with the class.
Otherwise, I'll
see you on Monday.
[CLASSROOM CHATTER]